l'expérience ne vient pas de moi parce
que j'ai l'occasion ainsi souvent dit ça
fait ça aussi mais j'étais avec les
parents autant il n'y avait pas tout ça
de technologie y avait pas tous a donné
telle instruction
c'était l'intelligence qu'on avait et on
savait tout faire à la main y avait pas
de machine est rien du tout alors c'est
pour cette raison j'ai travaillé pendant
la guerre a mis à l'honneur de mon âge
me donne ce que vous voyez là mais faut
être sérieux dans la vie chaque jouet à
son histoire parce que il s'agit pas de
dire j'ai aussi furent jeu suffire se
jura mais pourquoi lorsqu'on dit l'arrêt
cristal
l'arel cristal à son histoire et à vers
plusieurs hypercrystal selon le bi et
avait un gars tu étais ce talent et on
faisait aussi les chroniques avec de la
terre grâce qu'on faisait
mais seulement si ça qu'on appelle
l'amour du voisin des camarades locaux
ressortait à l'école on est tout tout
tout jouer qu'on peut connaître et de
résister dans les grands ce sens les
joueurs d'attentes d'autrefois jeux
traditionnels mais benno audard vraiment
évrier offert commission
on dira pas ce cancer qu'est née cette
manie sahara mais vous déjà allé
chercher loin ou dlouhy mémoire et où
rivard se et vous allez mon épopée à
quentin pour moi n'est tout pout pout
pout beaucoup alors il n'y en bague
ailleurs a à présent
est-ce que vous à 83 ans au transmettent
team mayumi on transmette guisti
mommayou conditions dans la jeunesse de
maintenance et palau c'est par leur
histoire c'est pas ça mais parfois ils
les oublient jolie fille fait revenir
parfois ne laisse pas longtemps parce
qu'elle n'aime pas aux médias c'est leur
tête il veut faire c'est une autre
génération dire vraiment dégrafé mon
utopie à la demande est rare et au pis
moi c'est un vrai plaisir le rouet ça
allait et que vous viviez puis à cela
mais on n'hésite pas à la portée de tout
le monde mais j'ai déjà fait beaucoup de
choses à l'heure actuelle je peux pas
passer la main j'ai un fils
ces ingénieurs de son vivant à marseille
il veut pas venir prendre la relève si
je trouve quelqu'un ce serait un grand
plaisir ou les apprendre ce que j'ai
appris pour qu'il puisse continuer ça
c'est bien dommage c'est dommage j'ai
fait un film de 52 minutes
j'ai payé 8 millions euros pour faire le
film
pourquoi c'est pour y ait un support
pour l'avenir qu'on ne serait pas là
pour qu'on passe aux jeunes atteints